using all I've learned I'm cooking a
dish that does justice to my culinary
adventures nobody's going to help you
right I'm really on my own and to make
matters worse Seema's bringing some
influential food critics since some
absolutely fantastic stuff all week
from the desert to the jungle to even on
the train so time to put that into
practice and basically as it is around
Z's world the knives are out first thing
I do get my chickens off the bone take
off the legs take off the breasts get
them into marinade at the same time get
a chicken stock going the dish I'm
staking my reputation on is slow cooked
chicken with cinnamon cardamon and
clothes on they're really nice sort of
brown fragrant stock aromatic not like
any normal chicken stock you'd find in
the UK in with that cinnamon this
delicate chicken stock will be the base
of my sauce so
very [ __ ] water how'd you get that no
wonder there's no clunking water lowest
pissing out down the bottom Jesus that's
not normal well if there's one thing I'm
learning the hard way
it's don't cook an important dish like
this in a poorly equipped kitchen or no
one speaks English cling film him film
no Japanese temple no no Jay don't worry
as soon now I'm not like this but like a
[Music]
now burn my [ __ ] onions star anis
aniseed star star star star star star in
the skies
star anise seed fennel star there are no
[ __ ] wave up me [ __ ] me star anis I
need know if I succeed tonight it will
be a miracle at this rate I'm in this
[ __ ] now
yeah everyone stands and stares and
[ __ ] last I'm in the [ __ ] now and i
marinate the chicken now in the green
for fire this marinade is adapted from
the one I used for the goat biryani at
the wedding chilli touch a clove powder
cumin a little bit of turmeric a little
bit of salt and a little bit of sugar
get that mixed in thing you know I'm on
the fly Joe it's a collection of what
we've seen where we've been a week
you're more importantly you know if it
doesn't work I'm gonna look [ __ ]
stupid so it has to work all right
chicken the breasts in so I go
I found a pumpkin to make a puree
there's no conventional oven to bake it
in here so time to use the one golden
rule of indian cookery think on your
feet improvise like we did in the jungle
i want to borrow your tandoori oven yeah
thank you
[ __ ] that's hot
yep perfect
[Music]
right spend an hour to go just starting
the sauce now yeah for the chicken it's
based on that stock from the chicken
study down the onions the garlic the
fresh tomatoes here then we add the
stock into that blend it and then finish
it with a touch of cream
Seema's decided to check up on me
she's invited a lot of influential
Indian foodies tonight
and no howdy
yeah bro chicken how's it going it's
been yeah it's been amazing but
tonight's the big night right tonight
I've got an apron in the car no choice
is good but can I take a sneak peek at
what you're doing
sneak peek pumpkin puree we was roasted
in the tandoor oven with a little bit of
cumin okay so that was almost video
niblets a pain the ass ago there's no
ovens here possibilities possibilities
hot [ __ ] I'm let me see there yeah let
me go around and take a look there am i
doing thank you
copy that's missing promising it's not
finished yet me I see you okay bye
thanks darling
just remember today is your day today's
my day [ __ ] me
I've lost time cooking in this basic
kitchen and Seema's food critic guests
have already arrived
so 7z just started customers are walking
in only do now these chicken breasts
just say them off this one the new dish
oh yeah a movement but force no good
okay if we don't like this no question
can be given back sooner sooner
okay first one from the jungle to the
desert and a huge exquisite wedding
banquet my North Indian expedition has
all come down to this my slow cooked
chicken is ready to go out I'm finishing
the dish with saffron flavored egg like
those I use in the goat biryani go
please go let's go go then let's go
[Music]
hmm okay so he's given his word standing
yeah I mean I that I really like it this
it's different it's if the table is
ain't really different to all the dishes
they've had here till now I love the
succulent nests of the chicken it's not
stringy it's not and it's and it isn't a
very heavy heavy kind of craving it's a
wonderful mix using Indian spices but
not over someone is approaching Indian
food or the food of Omaha no what about
with our cream three Gordon so I've got
to tell you you can brilliantly and
really liked it already no tell you what
it deceptively initially look like and I
love listen I wipe the plate clean come
out okay it's just unreal you to the
public to the public delis fine
[Music]
ladies how are we nice to see you
good to see you too gumball I want you
to meet everybody
right that's Gordon good evening ladies
gentlemen welcome
how was the chicken has a very distinct
light happy flavor before you ask me any
questions right swiftly is there
anything left at the boat is a good sign
it's delicious
did you enjoy it fabula yes in fact I
think they should stick around the menu
I'd order it again yeah that came here
again a different view did I pass
that's an honor thank you so much
it's been an incredible week but for me
what I have discovered here is that
Indian food is far superior than what
we're used to seeing at home so now got
the taste of it on an off the beaten
track and maybe into the unknown